الاحتجاجات ليست ايه الاولى منذ اجراءات
رئيس قيس سعيد وشوارع التونسيه تشهد
احتجاجات متفاوته ما الذي يميز
احتجاجات اليوم فضلا عن انها احياء لذكرى
ثوره همم ثوره تونسيه
صغيره كانت رافضه الانقلاب مكونه اساسا من
الاحزاب ال- ال- الحاكمه سابقا النهضه
الاعتناء في الكرامه وكذلك تونس ثم
تدريجيا بدا تتساوى قد ذكرنا في اكثر من
مره ان اا سياسه قيس سعيد هي نفسها التي
تجمع همم في نهايه الامر نحن اليوم نتيجه
هذا المسار تتويج همم مخيف بالنسبه الى
همم سعيد وحقيقه يعني عندما ترى كل
الاحزاب تقريبا
هي صغيره جدا في الواقع ولا وليست مؤثره
على ارض الواقع بالنسبه
25% في الورقه موجوده على وسائل التواصل
ولكنها على مستوى الارضيه على الواقع ليست
موجوده لدرجه همم
نظر الان الحصيله ان تقريبا كل شارع
السياسي اصبح مناهض لقيس سعيد والهجره
لا لا نراه كيف سيخرج كيس سعيد من هذا
الوضع خاصه وان ختامه هو نفسه لا يشجع على
شيء من هذا القبيح خاصه كذلك انه حتى
المجموعات التي كانت تسانده مثل الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل والذي كان دائما ينقض
الحكومه رغم انه يعرف جيدا ان هذه الحكومه
ليست اكثر من مجرد ظل الرئيس
وكان يطالب دائما بالحوار وان يكون عنصر
في الحوار وانظر على عدم زياده في يعني في
الاجور وثلاث سنوات من السلم الاجتماعي
ولكن سياس قيس سعيد يعني همم يعني
اعترضتهم تقريبا من مساره
لم يجددا من التواصل مع هذه التيارات
الاحذيه السياسيه محاوله الحضور معها رغم
ان بعض الامناء العام للاتحاد ما زال يكرر
الراي القديم وهو انهم لا يعترفون بمن
يتحدث عن انقلاب في نهايه الامر لا ندري
من سيقف
مستقبل غير القوى الصلبه وهو ما يعتبره
يعني همم منافسون او اعدائه يعتبرونه نقطه
ضعف اساسيه وستودي بوجود وجوده السياسي